Reduce in Cub is two passes. Reduce in Cub is two passes. Yeah. Because instead of communicating between threads, it's more efficient to have all of the thread blocks reduce locally right into an array and then do a second pass that reduces that final array. So in CUDA on NVIDIA GPUs, you tend to have hundreds of thousands of threads, you know, many, many inputs,
Cub中的Reduce是两遍处理。Cub中的Reduce是两遍处理。是的。因为与其在线程之间进行通信，不如让所有的线程块在本地直接归约到一个数组中，然后再进行第二遍处理来归约那个最终数组，这样效率更高。所以在NVIDIA GPU的CUDA中，你通常会有成千上万个线程，你知道，有非常非常多的输入，
and you tend to have maybe thousands of blocks. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 174, recorded on March 6, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we continue part two of our discussion of parallel chunk buy. Okay, Connor, I'm going to show you a function signature you've got if we've got a function chunk by it takes a range an output iterator and a predicate and what it does is it chunks up the input according to the predicate. So it creates chunks of elements for which the predicate returns true. And whenever there's an element for which the predicate returns false, then that's the start of a new chunk. And then it assigns these subranges, it assigns it into the output iterator.
而且你通常会有几千个块。欢迎收听ADSP播客，第174集，录制于2024年3月6日。我是Connor，今天和我的联合主持人Bryce一起，我们继续关于并行chunk by讨论的第二部分。好的，Connor，我要给你展示一个函数签名，如果我们有一个函数chunk by，它接收一个范围、一个输出迭代器和一个谓词，它的作用是根据谓词将输入分块。所以它会为谓词返回true的元素创建块。每当有一个元素使谓词返回false时，那就是一个新块的开始。然后它将这些子范围分配给输出迭代器。
How do you implement this chunk by algorithm in parallel? I mean, chunk by does nothing, so there's nothing to implement. Perfect. Done. Woo, folks! You missed the prompt. I'd missed the prom? The prompt.
你如何并行实现这个chunk by算法？我的意思是，chunk by什么都不做，所以没什么可实现的。完美。完成了。呜，伙计们！你们错过了提示。我错过了提示？提示。
The prompt? Yes. I was going to say, why did I miss prom? It doesn't have anything to do with this. You've missed the prompt. I mean, chunk. This is not a view. This is an algorithm called chunk by where it needs to produce an output sequence of
提示？是的。我本来想说，我为什么会错过舞会（prom）？这和这没关系。你错过了提示。我的意思是，chunk。这不是一个视图。这是一个叫做chunk by的算法，它需要产生一个输出序列，
sub ranges. I mean, even if this isn't a view, I literally would, like, unless if you're calling, you know, two vector after the view thing, which is where my head's at right now, literally, I wouldn't change the shape of the data. I would create a second thing called flags. You know, whether you even want to materialize that or not,
包含子范围。我的意思是，即使这不是一个视图，我真的会，除非你在视图之后调用了to vector，这就是我现在的想法，我真的不会改变数据的形状。我会创建第二个东西叫做标志。你知道，无论你是否想实现它，
you could just do it with a transform iterator, zip iterator trick. You can't do this one lazily. I'm not saying you're doing it lazily, but like until you need to print it, you don't actually need to do anything. And it doesn't need to be a scan. It's just literally... How are you implementing this in parallel? What do you mean? A transform iterator?
你都可以只用转换迭代器、zip迭代器技巧来完成。你不能懒惰地做这个。我不是说你在懒惰地做，但就像在你需要打印它之前，你实际上不需要做任何事情。而且它不需要是一个扫描。它只是字面上……你是如何并行实现这个的？你什么意思？转换迭代器？
That already is parallelizable. Okay. Describe your implementation again. All right. So if I need to, like, to me, I'm, like, stuck in view land because, like, chunk by by itself, like, you rarely ever want that. But if literally what you want to do in parallel is write to a screen and you've got a million elements and you want to chunk by a binary predicate,
那已经是可并行化的了。好的。再次描述你的实现。好的。所以如果我需要，对我来说，我就像被困在视图领域，因为就像chunk by本身，你很少会想要那个。但如果字面上你想在并行中做的是打印到屏幕上，并且你有一百万个元素，你想通过一个二元谓词进行chunk by，
which is what chunk by does, and you want, like, the bracket and and the left bracket right bracket indicating where your chunks are i literally wouldn't change the data at all all it would be is a printing mechanism and i would create a transform iterator composed with a zip iterator that gives you two elements at a time and your transform iterator is going to take that binary predicate and then you're basically just going to like however you do printing in parallel to the screen and anytime what is this printing
这就是chunk by所做的，并且你想要，比如，左括号和右括号来指示你的块在哪里，我真的根本不会改变数据。它只是一个打印机制，我会创建一个由zip迭代器组成的转换迭代器，它一次给你两个元素，你的转换迭代器将采用那个二元谓词，然后你基本上只是，无论你如何并行打印到屏幕上，并且任何时候，这是什么打印？
like my point is the output that I want is a vector of sub ranges not printing I want you to produce a vector of sub ranges well if that's the case then it's a bit more complicated. I mean, I feel like it's, why would you want that?
我的意思是，我想要的输出是一个子范围的向量，而不是打印。我想要你产生一个子范围的向量。好吧，如果是这样的话，那就有点复杂了。我的意思是，我觉得，你为什么要那个？
Okay, but that's not the prompt. But I think in general, you're always going to, there's always an operation after chunk by, whether it's a permutation of the elements in each chunk or a reduction. But the... So materialize... Answering this question answers how you would implement this in parallel when you're composing it with other operations. It answers a way to do that.
好吧，但那不是提示。但我认为总的来说，你总是会，在chunk by之后总会有一个操作，无论是每个块中元素的排列还是归约。但是……所以实现……回答这个问题就回答了当你把它与其他操作组合时，你将如何并行实现它。它回答了一种那样做的方法。
With my way where you just have a lazy basically mask that determines where your stuff is. I don't see how you could do this lazily like that in parallel. Like what does reduced by key do? That comes by. It's a scan. It's all scans, buddy. Reduced by key is a scan. Yeah.
用我的方法，你只是有一个懒惰的、基本上是掩码的东西来确定你的东西在哪里。我不明白你怎么能在并行中懒惰地那样做。比如reduced by key做什么？那是chunk by。这是一个扫描。全是扫描，伙计。Reduced by key是一个扫描。是的。
Well, I don't think that's the only way to implement that. Okay, well, you let me be the parallel programming expert. I let you be the programming languages expert. Stay in your corner, buddy. Doing that via scan versus like a bunch of different reductions that then the results just get copied. I mean, I think that's, well, no, for reduced by key. Like a scan by key, obviously, inclusive scan by key, obviously that's a scan, but a reduced by key, if you're telling me that's implemented with a scan, maybe that is the best way to do it.
嗯，我不认为那是实现它的唯一方法。好吧，好吧，让我成为并行编程专家。我让你成为编程语言专家。待在你的角落里，伙计。通过扫描来做，而不是像一堆不同的归约，然后结果只是被复制。我的意思是，我认为那是，好吧，不，对于reduced by key。就像scan by key，显然，inclusive scan by key，显然那是一个扫描，但reduced by key，如果你告诉我那是用扫描实现的，也许那是最好的方法。
I'm just saying that sounds suspicious. Because you, yeah, you have to do it. I'm pretty sure. But anyways, you're getting us off topic. We can check that in a moment. How do you implement? Stop questioning the utility of the thing and just trust me and answer how do you implement chunk by.
我只是说这听起来很可疑。因为你，是的，你必须这样做。我很确定。但无论如何，你让我们偏离了主题。我们稍后可以检查一下。你如何实现？停止质疑这件事的效用，只管相信我，回答你如何实现chunk by。
All right, so if you actually want to materialize a vector of vectors, which for the record sounds like a bad idea to me. Sounds like a bad idea to me, folks. It's a vector of subranges. If you actually want to do that, and you're starting off with a single vector on your device, you're going to end up... It's the same thing that you want to do for copy of, basically.
好吧，所以如果你真的想实现一个向量的向量，这对我来说听起来是个坏主意。伙计们，这听起来是个坏主意。这是一个子范围的向量。如果你真的想那样做，并且你从设备上的一个单一向量开始，你最终会……这基本上和你想要做的copy if是一样的。
Yeah, I mean, there's two different ways in my head. You can create that mask and then do the plus scans and do a bunch of copy ifs based on those indices. Or you can calculate the indices of where the starts of your new chunks are and perform copy ifs to each of your new vectors within your vector. So there's two different ways to do it. I don't actually know which one's best. So one of them, yes, is very similar to the first one that I described. Okay, so what I've got here is how I've done it, which is three passes just like a copy of.
是的，我的脑海里有两种不同的方法。你可以创建那个掩码，然后做加法扫描，并根据那些索引做一堆copy if。或者你可以计算你的新块开始的索引，并对你的向量中的每个新向量执行copy if。所以有两种不同的方法来做。我实际上不知道哪种最好。所以其中一个，是的，非常类似于我描述的第一个。好的，所以我这里有我做它的方法，也就是三遍处理，就像copy if一样。
The first pass, we build up a vector of flags, one for each element-ish. Now, chunk by takes a predicate that's applied to every two adjacent elements, so it's not just a straight transform. So we do a essentially an adjacent transform to build up the flags. And then we've got a vector of flags where there's one flag for every input element and the flag is true if the chunk by predicate returned true for that particular element. And then we're going to introduce a struct. We're going to call it interval.
第一遍，我们建立一个标志向量，每个元素一个。现在，chunk by接收一个应用于每两个相邻元素的谓词，所以它不仅仅是一个直接的转换。所以我们基本上做一个相邻转换来建立标志。然后我们有一个标志向量，其中每个输入元素都有一个标志，如果chunk by谓词对那个特定元素返回true，则标志为true。然后我们将引入一个结构体。我们称之为interval。
And this struct is going to be the thing that we're going to scan. And an interval has four different components. One has the flag, which is just the flag from the transform. It's just a bool. It also has an integer, which is the index. And this is the same index from the copy if, where this is the index of what is the current location that...
这个结构体将是我们扫描的东西。一个interval有四个不同的组件。一个有标志，这只是来自转换的标志。它只是一个布尔值。它还有一个整数，也就是索引。这和copy if中的索引是一样的，这是当前位置的索引，即……
It's a plus scan on your flags, Vic. Yes, it's a plus scan on your flags, Vic. Yes, it's a plus scan on your flags, Vic. But then we also have an int start. And this is the start of whatever the current chunk is. And then we also have an int end.
这是对你的标志的加法扫描，Vic。是的，这是对你的标志的加法扫描，Vic。是的，这是对你的标志的加法扫描，Vic。但我们还有一个int start。这是当前块的开始。然后我们还有一个int end。
An end is just a count of... An int end. An end is just a count of, like for every element, we just count once. You follow so far? Maybe. Keep going. Okay. And then we're going to do a scan of the flags array. And we convert a flag to an interval as follows.
一个end只是一个计数……一个int end。一个end只是一个计数，比如对于每个元素，我们只计数一次。你跟上到目前为止了吗？也许。继续。好的。然后我们将对标志数组进行扫描。我们将标志转换为interval如下。
The flag parameter of the interval is just whatever the Boolean flag is, and then zero for the index, zero for the start, and one for the end. Because remember, the end is just the count of how many elements we have. So the way that you take a representation of a particular element, like any arbitrary element, and turn it into an interval is you compute the predicate for it, and that's the flag member of the interval and then index is zero, start is zero
interval的标志参数只是布尔标志是什么，然后索引为0，开始为0，结束为1。因为记住，结束只是我们拥有的元素数量的计数。所以你获取特定元素（比如任何任意元素）的表示并将其转换为interval的方法是，你计算它的谓词，这就是interval的标志成员，然后索引是0，开始是0，
and then end is one because you've got one element that you're dealing with. Follow so far? Maybe, keep going. Okay. And then our reduction operator for our, sorry, our scan operator, it takes a left and a right both of which are intervals
然后结束是1，因为你正在处理一个元素。跟上到目前为止了吗？也许，继续。好的。然后我们的归约运算符，抱歉，我们的扫描运算符，它接收一个左和一个右，它们都是interval，
and it combines them together and it always takes the flag from the right interval just because of the the nature of how this scan is applied from left to right, it's always going to be representing the element on the right when we combine things. So the newly returned interval from this sum function will have the flag of the right one. And if the flag of the right interval is true, then the index is the left index plus the right index. Because, and that's, yeah. I won't explain that any further. But if the flag on the right is not true, then it's the left index plus the right index plus one.
它将它们组合在一起，并且它总是从右interval获取标志，仅仅是因为这个扫描从左到右应用的性质，当我们组合事物时，它总是代表右边的元素。所以这个sum函数返回的新interval将具有右边的标志。如果右interval的标志为true，那么索引就是左索引加上右索引。因为，是的。我不会再解释那个了。但如果右边的标志不是true，那么它就是左索引加上右索引加1。
Because if it's not true, then we've started a new group and we need to increment the index. Then for the start field, which represents the beginning of the current chunk that we're working on. If the flag is true, then we are continuing the current chunk. And so we add, they'll start from the left and they'll start from the right. But if the flag is false, then we're at the start of a new chunk. Well, where do we start a new chunk? Well, we're starting a new chunk at this element. So what is the position of this element? The position of this element is the end of the left,
因为如果它不是true，那么我们已经开始了一个新组，我们需要增加索引。然后对于start字段，它代表我们正在处理的当前块的开始。如果标志为true，那么我们正在继续当前块。所以我们加上，它们将从左边开始，它们将从右边开始。但如果标志为false，那么我们处于一个新块的开始。好吧，我们在哪里开始一个新块？好吧，我们在这个元素处开始一个新块。那么这个元素的位置是什么？这个元素的位置是左边的结束，
is the count of how many elements we've gone to thus far. And fortunately, we have that count. And then the end, which is, again, the count of how many elements. It's just like if you were going to do a stood count. End is always just the end on the left plus the end on the right. And so you do that scan with that operator. And then you do a gather if. Or I'll describe it in terms of a 4-H. and so the 4h is it's a little bit tricky because you end up needing to have that flag parameter
是我们到目前为止已经经过的元素数量的计数。幸运的是，我们有那个计数。然后结束，也就是，再次，元素数量的计数。这就像如果你要执行一个std count。结束总是左边的结束加上右边的结束。所以你用那个运算符执行那个扫描。然后你执行一个gather if。或者我将用for-each来描述它。所以for-each有点棘手，因为你最终需要有那个标志参数，
in the interval thing but I also have to keep the original flags around because I end up overwriting the flags in there and there's maybe a slightly more elegant way to structure this but the 4h functor if the flag is false then that means that we're
在interval那个东西里，但我还必须保留原始标志，因为我最终覆盖了那里的标志，也许有一种稍微优雅的方法来构建这个，但for-each函子，如果标志为false，那就意味着我们
at the end read an element that represents the end of a chunk and so we need to write that chunk to the output iterator. And we know what index we're going to write it to in the output iterator because that's a part of this interval data structure. But do you understand how this algorithm works? This is the same style of algorithm. It's the same implementation that we have for copy if. We did three fundamental things.
在末尾读取一个代表块结束的元素，所以我们需要将那个块写入输出迭代器。我们知道我们要把它写入输出迭代器的哪个索引，因为那是这个interval数据结构的一部分。但你明白这个算法是如何工作的吗？这是同一种风格的算法。这和我们为copy if所做的实现是一样的。我们做了三件基本的事情。
First of all, we computed the flags. Second, we did a scan that scanned the flags and computed some indices into the original input. And third, we did some gathering operation, which used those indices and those flags to write to the output in the correct positions with the correct values. This is how we implement stream compaction. And my argument is that this implementation strategy, the thing that we do for copy if, we would do the same thing for chunk by. It's the same parallel algorithm. Flag building, scan, gather. And that is why I say to you that I am thinking of these grouping operations as removing operations because they're going to be implemented in parallel in the same exact way. So I have three comments and I'm not even sure
首先，我们计算了标志。第二，我们做了一个扫描，扫描了标志并计算了原始输入中的一些索引。第三，我们做了一些收集操作，它使用那些索引和那些标志以正确的值写入正确的输出位置。这就是我们实现流压缩的方法。我的论点是，这种实现策略，我们为copy if所做的事情，我们将为chunk by做同样的事情。这是同一种并行算法。标志构建、扫描、收集。这就是为什么我对你说，我把这些分组操作视为删除操作，因为它们将以完全相同的方式并行实现。所以我有两个评论，我甚至不确定
if I remember all three of them so I might forget the third one while you do that I'm going to go look at reduced by key but continue alright my first comment I mean Bryce kind of needs to hear these
我是否记得所有三个，所以我可能会忘记第三个，在你做那个的时候，我要去看看reduced by key，但继续。好的，我的第一个评论。我的意思是Bryce有点需要听到这些，
but he needs to refute them if they're wrong I didn't fully understand so I think the actually the first comment is yes I agree that they all share the same flags plus scan on flags gather if style.
但他需要反驳它们，如果它们是错的话。我没有完全理解，所以我认为实际上第一个评论是，是的，我同意它们都共享相同的标志加标志扫描、gather if风格。
That's my first comment. So I agree with you there. My second comment is I'm not sure I fully understood the struct across blocks or chunks, but I don't think that's important. I understand what the purpose of them was. I was thinking in my head, what if there's a bunch of chunks within a single block? Is that a problem? But my guess is that it comprehensively covers all the cases, whether a chunk is longer than a block and straddles both the left and right side of it, whether it's split by a block
那是我的第一个评论。所以我在这里同意你。我的第二个评论是，我不确定我是否完全理解了跨块或块的结构体，但我不认为那很重要。我理解它们的目的是什么。我在脑海里想，如果一个块内有一堆块怎么办？那是个问题吗？但我的猜测是，它全面涵盖了所有情况，无论一个块是否比一个块长，并跨越了它的左侧和右侧，无论它是否被一个块分割，
or there's a bunch of them inside a bunch of chunks inside a block. I'm guessing your struck covers all those situations, correct? Right. It doesn't cover them explicitly. It's just by property of the scan. Yes. So as long as I didn't fully understand that, but my guess is that it works for that, so we're good to go there.
或者一个块内有一堆块。我猜你的结构体涵盖了所有这些情况，对吧？对。它没有明确涵盖它们。这只是扫描的属性。是的。所以只要我没有完全理解那个，但我的猜测是它对那个有效，所以我们在这里准备好了。
My third and final comment, and this is the most important one, is that although I made my first comment about agreeing with the structure, I think I still morally take issue with referring to that flags plus scan and then gather if as dropping because I can see why you're saying that because— How about compacting or combining? Those are less objectionable. Hang on. Can you at least see how some could view chunk by, which applies a predicate?
我的第三个也是最后一个评论，这是最重要的一点，虽然我对我同意结构发表了第一个评论，但我认为我仍然在道德上反对将那个标志加扫描然后gather if称为删除，因为我可以看出你为什么那样说，因为——关于压缩或组合怎么样？那些不太令人反感。等等。你至少能看出有些人怎么看待chunk by，它应用了一个谓词吗？
Think about what chunk by does. Chunk by, it says, okay, I'm going to start at the beginning of the sequence, and I'm going to apply this predicate and start accumulating elements until I hit one that's false, and then I'm going to pop out a chunk. Well, I mean, specifically, it's a binary predicate that's applied to adjacent elements. But could you see that as an operation that combines things together? Yes, but it doesn't drop anything.
想想chunk by做什么。Chunk by，它说，好的，我将从序列的开头开始，我将应用这个谓词并开始累积元素，直到我遇到一个为false的元素，然后我将弹出一个块。好吧，我的意思是，具体来说，它是一个应用于相邻元素的二元谓词。但你能把它看作是一个将事物组合在一起的操作吗？是的，但它没有删除任何东西。
The moral issue that I have is with saying that it drops stuff which is right but in a world where we have to do our work distribution a priori we end up we end up where we distribute a certain number of work items to each thread and then as we do this combining operation, some of the threads have to bow out. It's like back to that example of the word count where we had 20 threads but four words. Some of the threads have to choose not to participate and that's what I mean by dropping.
我有的道德问题是关于说它删除了东西，这是对的，但在一个我们必须先验地进行工作分配的世界里，我们最终，我们最终将一定数量的工作项分配给每个线程，然后当我们进行这个组合操作时，一些线程必须退出。这就像回到那个字数统计的例子，我们有20个线程但只有四个字。一些线程必须选择不参与，这就是我所说的删除。
Well, so I still take issue with it because if an execution strategy necessitates some kind of dropping, the execution strategy has nothing to do with the algorithm from a semantic point of view. But if you think about the algorithm differently, then that can lead you to an execution strategy that you might not have thought of. I'm not disagreeing with that. But from a semantic point of view of what Chunk Buy does, it doesn't drop. Just because an execution strategy does. I choose to think of it as dropping. I'm not saying that you're wrong for thinking about it. But you're trying to convince me to think about it that way.
好吧，所以我仍然对此有异议，因为如果执行策略需要某种删除，执行策略在语义上与算法无关。但如果你以不同的方式思考算法，那么这可能会导致你可能没有想到的执行策略。我不是不同意这一点。但从chunk by做什么的语义角度来看，它不会删除。仅仅因为执行策略这样做。我选择把它看作是删除。我不是说你认为它是错的。但你试图说服我那样思考。
I'm not saying that you should think about it that way in general. What are you saying? I'm saying that if you're implementing it in parallel, that's a good mindset to have. Also, let's talk about reduce by key. I did confirm it is implemented by a scan. And in fact, interestingly, it's a by key scan. So it is very similar to these algorithms. It's a by key scan so it is very similar
我不是说你应该那样思考。你在说什么？我说的是，如果你在并行实现它，那是一个很好的心态。另外，让我们谈谈reduce by key。我确实确认它是通过扫描实现的。事实上，有趣的是，它是一个by key扫描。所以它与这些算法非常相似。它是一个by key扫描，所以它与
to these algorithms it's a by key scan? that's even worse than implemented by a scan well how else would you do you do the scan to compute the groups you could do a reduce by key with a
这些算法非常相似，它是一个by key扫描？那比通过扫描实现更糟糕。好吧，你还会怎么做？你做扫描来计算组。你可以用一个
reduction. With the same little struct that you're building up with little pieces of information that like when your chunks, because that's basically a reduce by key, is exactly what we're talking about. It's a chunk by followed by a transform where the operation that your transform is
归约来做reduce by key。用你正在构建的带有小块信息的相同小结构体，比如当你的块，因为那基本上是一个reduce by key，正是我们正在谈论的。它是一个chunk by，后面跟着一个转换，你的转换正在
applying is a reduction. That's exactly what this is. And in the case where you know that that operation is a reduction, a.k.a. a reduce by key, then you know that you definitely don't need to do any scanning stuff. You can have some object that, sure, it's got some internal vector that might be growing over time as you are, you know. You'd have to turn it, basically each of your elements into one of these structs. And then at the end of the day, you're going to end up with a vector of these structs where the only thing you care about is the reduced element. But you definitely don't need to do it by with a scan or a scan by key.
应用的操作是一个归约。这正是它。在你知道那个操作是一个归约（即reduce by key）的情况下，那么你知道你绝对不需要做任何扫描的事情。你可以有一些对象，当然，它有一些内部向量，随着你，你知道，可能会随着时间增长。你基本上必须把你的每个元素变成这些结构体之一。然后最终，你最终会得到一个这些结构体的向量，你唯一关心的是归约后的元素。但你绝对不需要通过扫描或scan by key来做。
Maybe that is actually the best implementation. Lord knows I'm not a CUDA ninja when it comes to implementing this stuff. So I don't actually know, you know, what is best. knows I'm not a CUDA ninja when it comes to implementing this stuff, so I don't actually know, you know, what is best. But I'm saying that, like, when I think about, you know, how to implement a copy if it matched up with what we have in Thrust. But when I think about how to implement a reduce by key, I definitely don't think of scan, and I definitely don't think of scan by key. I see how you can definitely implement them in terms of those, but like a scan by key, my guess is what they do is they do the scan and then they just do a copy if where they're copying the last element of each of the scans correct um
也许那实际上是最好的实现。上帝知道当涉及到实现这些东西时，我不是CUDA忍者。所以我实际上不知道，你知道，什么是最好的。知道当涉及到实现这些东西时，我不是CUDA忍者，所以我实际上不知道，你知道，什么是最好的。但我说的是，比如，当我思考，你知道，如何实现一个copy if时，它与我们在Thrust中拥有的相匹配。但当我思考如何实现一个reduce by key时，我绝对不会想到扫描，我也绝对不会想到scan by key。我明白你如何绝对可以用那些来实现它们，但就像scan by key，我的猜测是他们所做的是他们做扫描，然后他们只是做copy if，在那里他们复制每个扫描的最后一个元素，对吧，嗯
i would expect to see like i would expect to see a gather if or a copy if where yeah there's a there's a gather if in the scan yeah and the gather if is just looking into the final index of each scan, which means that you've materialized a whole scan, a whole like, you know, chunks worth of data only. It's like, it's basically when we talk about the missing reduction where we're doing the associative only reduce, but the only way to do that currently because we don't have that reduction, it's missing.
我会期望看到，比如我会期望看到一个gather if或copy if，是的，扫描中有一个gather if，是的，gather if只是查看每个扫描的最终索引，这意味着你已经实现了一个完整的扫描，一个完整的，你知道，块的数据量。这就像，这基本上就是当我们谈论缺失的归约时，我们正在做仅关联的归约，但目前做到这一点的唯一方法是因为我们没有那个归约，它缺失了。
We have to basically do an inclusive scan and then just take the last element that's what we're doing here for every single chunk bryce is thinking he's he's not ignoring me he's just staring up at the ceiling yeah i just remember what reduce actually looks like but let's look at scan by key because you mentioned how skate well now scan by key actually does the um does the the flags thing to scan by key and reduce by key look end up looking very similar and and cub today that's good i'm trying to think about whether there's a better way to do reduce by key is there a reason that it has to be a scan oh you know why probably is a scan because the reduce by key that I'm talking about, my version, you know what it needs? It needs the missing reduce. Building up one of those structs that you combine across blocks requires the associative only reduce.
我们基本上必须做一个包含扫描，然后只取最后一个元素，这就是我们在这里为每个块所做的。Bryce正在思考，他没有忽略我，他只是盯着天花板。是的，我只是记得归约实际上看起来是什么样子，但让我们看看scan by key，因为你提到了如何，好吧，现在scan by key实际上做了那个标志的事情，scan by key和reduce by key最终看起来非常相似，而且今天的cub，那很好，我正在考虑是否有更好的方法来做reduce by key，它必须是扫描有什么原因吗？哦，你知道为什么可能是扫描吗？因为我正在谈论的reduce by key，我的版本，你知道它需要什么吗？它需要缺失的归约。构建一个你在块之间组合的结构体需要仅关联的归约。
Yeah, but our reduce just happens to work that way. Okay, never mind. I forgot about that. So let's look at what does reduce do. Reduce. It'd be funny if it was a scan too. No, it's not. So it's got a block reduce,
是的，但我们的归约恰好是那样工作的。好的，没关系。我忘了那个。所以让我们看看归约做什么。归约。如果它也是一个扫描会很有趣。不，它不是。所以它有一个块归约，
but then, so in Cobb, a block reduce is something that just does a reduction within a set of blocks, but then you get to combine a block reduce but then so in cub a block reduce is something that just does a reduction within a set of blocks but then you get to combine a block reduce with some sort of global thing to um make it a device wide so the way that the way that scan works in in cub is there's this magical tile prefix thingy that wraps your operator. So you still call block scan in Cub, but you pass it in this magical wrapped version of your operator. And that wrapped version of the operator does all of the communication between the different blocks. So it's very clever because if you only want to do a block-wide scan,
但然后，所以在Cub中，块归约是只在块集合内进行归约的东西，但然后你得到组合一个块归约，但然后在Cub中，块归约是只在块集合内进行归约的东西，但然后你得到组合一个块归约与某种全局的东西来，嗯，使它成为设备范围的。所以扫描在Cub中工作的方式是，有这个神奇的瓦片前缀东西包裹你的运算符。所以你仍然在Cub中调用块扫描，但你传入了这个运算符的神奇包裹版本。而那个运算符的包裹版本完成了不同块之间的所有通信。所以它非常聪明，因为如果你只想做一个块范围的扫描，
you can use the block-wide scan primitive for it. But if you want to do a scan that communicates with other blocks, you don't have to use a different primitive. You just use that same primitive and you just plug in this operator that when it gets invoked, it will go and do the communication. And if you're interested in learning more about how that particular scan algorithm is implemented... Attend Thinking Parallel at ACCU 2024 in April. Think Parallel. Think Parallel. Ooh, is Think Parallel? Think Parallel is a better title,
你可以使用块范围的扫描原语。但如果你想做一个与其它块通信的扫描，你不必使用不同的原语。你只需使用相同的原语，只需插入这个运算符，当它被调用时，它就会去进行通信。如果你有兴趣了解更多关于那个特定扫描算法是如何实现的……参加2024年4月在ACCU上的Think Parallel演讲。Think Parallel。Think Parallel。哦，是Think Parallel吗？Think Parallel是一个更好的标题，
yeah. Think Parallel. Yeah. At ACCU 2024. I think in parallel is actually, I don't hate that title. What did a friend, Joao, who was a guest on Arraycast, when he listened to that episode, he was like, IBM's motto is think. Apple's motto is think different. NVIDIA's motto is think parallel, or should be. And then I was like, and then I said, yeah, we could keep going. And Netflix is don't think.
是的。Think Parallel。是的。在ACCU 2024。我认为Think Parallel实际上，我不讨厌那个标题。一位朋友，Joao，他是Arraycast的嘉宾，当他听那一集时，他说，IBM的座右铭是Think。苹果的座右铭是Think Different。NVIDIA的座右铭是Think Parallel，或者应该是。然后我说，然后我说，是的，我们可以继续。Netflix是Don't Think。
So where is the – OpenAI is We Can Think For You. Where is the communication here? So there's no – interesting. All right. Somewhere here there's got to be an atomic or somewhere there has to be some form of communication. For those that like to follow along, Bryce is at agent underscore reduce dot C-U-H in the C-C-C-L slash cub slash cub slash agent repository on the NVIDIA C-C-C-L GitHub repo.
那么通信在哪里？所以没有——有趣。好吧。在某处一定有一个原子操作，或者在某处一定有某种形式的通信。对于那些喜欢跟进的人，Bryce在NVIDIA C-C-C-L GitHub仓库的C-C-C-L/cub/cub/agent仓库中的agent_reduce.cuh。
We'll leave a permalink to the file in the show notes. Consentile. Transform op. We've also, we're going to wind this down in the next five minutes here because we've been recording for an hour and a half.
我们将在节目说明中留下该文件的永久链接。Consentile。转换操作。我们也，我们将在接下来的五分钟内结束这个，因为我们已经录制了一个半小时了。
This has a transform op that's built into it. That's clever. So we're calling reduce. Hang on. You hold on to this for a second. Testing, testing. Some things just happened.
这有一个内置的转换操作。那很聪明。所以我们正在调用归约。等等。你先拿着这个。测试，测试。有些事情刚刚发生了。
That was Bryce dropping his keyboard. I remember the answer. Reduce in Cub is two passes. Reduce in Cub is two passes. Reduce in Cub is two passes. Yeah. Because it's more, instead of communicating between threads, it's more efficient to have all of the thread blocks reduce locally right into an array, and then do a second pass that reduces that final array.
那是Bryce掉落了他的键盘。我记得答案。Cub中的Reduce是两遍处理。Cub中的Reduce是两遍处理。Cub中的Reduce是两遍处理。是的。因为与其在线程之间进行通信，不如让所有的线程块在本地直接归约到一个数组中，然后再进行第二遍处理来归约那个最终数组，这样效率更高。
So in CUDA on NVIDIA GPUs, you tend to have hundreds of thousands of threads, you know, many, many inputs. And you tend to have maybe thousands of blocks, you know, let's say, oh, 1,000 blocks for, like, you know, a good chunky run. Maybe if you have a smaller problem size, you might have a lot fewer blocks. And you have, like, up to hundreds of what we call SMs, which are the things that execute blocks. And you can have, I think like modern chips maybe have like 80 SMs. But each SM can have multiple blocks active at a time. I can't remember how many.
所以在NVIDIA GPU的CUDA中，你通常会有成千上万个线程，你知道，有非常非常多的输入。而且你通常会有几千个块，你知道，假设，哦，1000个块，比如，你知道，一个好的块运行。也许如果你有一个较小的问题规模，你可能会有少得多的块。而且你有，比如，多达数百个我们称之为SM的东西，它们是执行块的东西。而且你可以有，我想现代芯片可能有80个SM。但每个SM可以同时有多个块处于活动状态。我不记得有多少了。
It could be 16. So you could have a couple hundred blocks operating at the same time. So if you do a two-pass reduction, your first pass reduces whatever, regardless of input size, which could be millions, billions, trillions, down to order of magnitude of how many blocks you've launched, which is a few thousand. And then you do a second pass, and it could even be a serial pass, but the way that we do it in Cub is we do a second pass, which is we launch a single block to reduce those values from the, to reduce the aggregate sums from each one of the first passes blocks into a single result. And this approach requires no communication between blocks. So it's embarrassingly parallel across blocks. And this is why reduce by key has to can't, I think, do a two-pass approach like that because you have to handle the ends of each one of the reduced by key groups.
可能是16。所以你可以有几百个块同时运行。所以如果你做一个两遍归约，你的第一遍归约无论输入大小如何，这可能是数百万、数十亿、数万亿，减少到你启动的块数量的数量级，也就是几千个。然后你做第二遍，它甚至可以是一个串行遍，但我们在Cub中做它的方式是我们做第二遍，也就是我们启动一个单一的块来归约那些值，从第一遍块的每一个归约聚合和到一个单一的结果。这种方法在块之间不需要通信。所以它在块之间是令人尴尬地并行的。这就是为什么reduce by key必须，我认为，不能做那样的两遍方法，因为你必须处理每个reduce by key组的末尾。
Right? by key groups right like what if what if one of the blocks in the first pass spans two groups or three groups or four groups yeah i mean that's covered by like i said the same way where we had the whole missing reduction episode and we were doing the maximum consecutive ones where you had to build that struct that like carried information? But we could build a... So the thing that we use to communicate between blocks in a scan is called decoupled lookback. And if you want to learn more about that, come to my Think Parallel talk.
对吧？按键组，对吧？比如如果第一遍中的一个块跨越了两个组或三个组或四个组怎么办？是的，我的意思是，这就像我说的，我们有整个缺失的归约那一集，我们正在做最大连续1，你必须构建那个携带信息的结构体？但我们可以构建一个……所以我们在扫描中用来在块之间通信的东西叫做解耦回溯。如果你想了解更多关于那个的信息，来参加我的Think Parallel演讲。
But there's no reason that we couldn't use... I think the two-pass reduce would still work. You just... Maybe it would. You just need to be smart about... It's similar. We've talked about... But even if it doesn't,
但没有理由我们不能使用……我认为两遍归约仍然有效。你只是……也许它会。你只需要聪明一点……它很相似。我们谈论过……但即使它没有，
you could do it in one pass with a decoupled look back reduce that's that's probably slower we don't even have that right that's probably slower i thought yeah but the the piece the all of the pieces are there you can actually the communication thing which is like called like tile prefix callback up or something like that in cub that thing is not i think specific to scan um there's certainly there's a version of it for reduced by key um the it is weird that it does the scan. I wonder if the scan. Look at that.
你可以用解耦回溯归约在一步中完成它，那可能更慢，我们甚至没有那个，那可能更慢，我以为是的，但所有的部分都在那里，你实际上可以，那个通信东西，它被称为像tile prefix callback up或者Cub中的类似东西，那个东西我不认为特定于扫描，嗯，肯定有一个用于reduce by key的版本，它确实很奇怪，它做了扫描。我想知道扫描是否是因为键。因为我们通常。我们通常在有键时做扫描，但为什么？现在，Bryce就在拐角处。让我们回到两遍reduce by key。我不相信那有效。
Bryce is coming over to the dark side. I wonder if the scan is necessary because of the keys. Because we usually. We usually do a scan anytime we have keys, but why? And now, Bryce is right around the corner. Let's go back to the two pass reduced by key. I'm not convinced that works.
一定要在你的播客应用程序或ADSPthepodcast.com上查看这些节目说明，以获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听，我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量、高质量，这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts comments and questions thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day low quality high quantity that is the tagline of our podcast it's not the tagline our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请务必查看播客应用内或 ADSPthepodcast.com 上的节目笔记，获取我们今天节目中提到的所有内容的链接，以及 GitHub 讨论区的链接，您可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听，希望您喜欢，祝您有愉快的一天。低质量、高产量，这就是我们播客的口号。不对，那不是我们的口号，我们的口号是“充满信息碎片的混乱”。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。